eu sou contador de histórias então tudo
que eu posso fazer aqui é contar
histórias e eu quero antes de falar pra
vocês é a importância das histórias do
nosso mundo atual
eu vou começar por uma história que já
vai me ajudar a dizer da importância das
histórias e essa é de quando a verdade
gostaria de conhecer um palácio
bom a verdade ea verdade é uma coisa
abstrata para que ela entrasse no
palácio ela precisava de ter uma forma
uma forma qualquer
ela escolheu pra isso uma forma um corpo
de mulher
então ela tomou o corpo de mulher e foi
bater às portas do palácio hamas é
escolher um palácio muito especial
esse quadro vem lá do oriente portanto
ela escolheu o palácio do califa aérea o
palácio majestoso e ela foi bater nas
portas bateu à porta e veio guarda
atender e viu uma mulher completamente
nua diante dele e disse quem é a senhora
o que quer aqui eu chamo verdade e
gostaria de conhecer o palácio do nosso
khalifa
nada mais o guarda disse olha mas uma
mulher assim não sei se ela fica aqui
fora eu vou lá saber do vizir se a
senhora pode entrar lá ele foi lá ele
foi e perguntou dizer se essa mulher que
estava lá fora completamente nua pôde
entrar naquele palácio o verde se uma
mulher lá fora completamente nua quando
se chama ela disse o nome do guarda
disse sim ela diz que se chama verdade é
verdade aqui o nosso palácio nem pensava
em uma coisa dessa
você vai lá e diga pra ela que uma
mulher assim nua tão despudorada não
pode entrar no nosso palácio que ela vá
pelo caminho já lá foi o atleta foi
guarda e dispensou a mulher e disse olha
uma mulher assim tão despudorado não
pode entrar no palácio do nosso khalifa
siga pelos caminhos e alaa
ela foi mas aqui eu vejo que tem homens
aqui na nossa platéia tenha um homem
usado aqui na nossa platéia os homens
que conhecem bem as mulheres sabem que
ela não ia desistir porque porque num
corpo de mulher
ela era obstinada ela foi ela foi e ela
pensou eu entro e é naquele palácio
então ela se cobriu com as peles de
animais mal curtidas as mal cheirosas é
como se praticamente ela fosse aquele
animal ela se cobriu com aquilo e foi
bater nas portas do palácio e lá
chegando o guarda vai atender disse que
aqui conhecer o palácio do nosso khalifa
nada mais amanhã é assim aqui as coisas
não são assim e só espera que eu vou
saber do vizinho senhora pode entrar
aqui e lá foi ele perguntou o nome e foi
lá ela produzir e disse olha lá fora tem
uma mulher vestida com umas 15 espelhos
de animais assim mal cheirosas ainda
meio sangrando é feia e ela diz que quem
trava conhecer o nosso palácio
visite se uma mulher vestida dessa forma
querendo conhecer o nosso palácio como
ela chama ela diz como ela chama ela diz
que se chama acusação o que será de cada
um de nós é a acusação entrar aqui
dentro não não você vai lá fora e dica
pra ela que uma mulher vestida dessa
forma não pode entrar no nosso palácio
ele foi o quarto e disse me disse que
você não pode entrar aqui que vá pelos
caminhos de alá lá ela foi
ela foi mas já sabe ela estava em um
corpo de mulher o que significa é que
ela era caprichosa também ela disse eu
entro e é nesse palácio porque
justamente hora que ela ia saindo dali
era hora do crepúsculo o sol tava
começando a cair debate na cúpula
dourada do palácio do califa e vinha um
perfume de jazz lindos jardins daquele
palácio ela diz é isso que eu vou
conhecer
então foi se e se lavou como as
essências muito perfumadas passou óleos
essenciais por todo seu corpo e depois
ela vestia umas roupas assim com os
tecidos é um ambiente afã nos um pouco
de afagos de forma assim que você ia mas
não via e ela pintou os seus olhos com
call e ela colocou flores nos cabelos e
jóias muito delicadas e foi bater nas
portas do palácio ela bateu e lá veio o
quarto atender ele abriu a porta e disse
olá beleza e ela disse olha ele disse o
que gostaria tamanha formosura no nosso
palácio conhecê-lo nada mais disse ela
não haverá nenhum problema disse o
quarta no entanto tenho que anunciara
antes alves ir lá ficou a mulher lá foi
o guarda quando chegou na sala do visit
se na fora tem uma mulher que é um
espetáculo
ela veste umas roupas assim que a gente
não vê mas não vê a gente fica só
imaginando ela tem umas jóias que eu
nunca vi tão finas como essas
ela é perfumar o visit si e que mulher é
essa ela disse como ela se chama assim
ela diz que se chama fábula a a a fábula
aqui no nosso palácio mas que ela seja
recebida com honras de rainha e que toda
a nossa corte se coloque numa espécie de
um corredor assim por onde ela possa
passar e ser recebida por nós como toda
a dignidade que ela merece
assim entre a fábula no palácio ela
ficou o tempo que quiser ela comeu bebeu
ela contou muitas histórias clara era
fábula e depois de um tempo ela disse
que já ia se embora que ia conhecer
outros caminhos outros palácios outros
lugares e eles de ser o fábio por favor
não nos deixe ela disse
agora já é tempo que eu me vá e volte
quando quiser fábula sempre teremos as
portas abertas pra você e assim meus
amigos minhas amigas
a única forma como a verdade pode entrar
no palácio não foi nem nua e crua nem
sobre a forma de acusação foi como
fábula e se nós queremos falar de coisas
que às vezes parecem difíceis delicadas
e complicadas
nada melhor que chamar a fábula para nos
ajudar então pois muito bem eu vou falar
pra vocês muito rapidamente sobre
algumas coisas algumas características
que são muito importantes e eu penso
sobre contar histórias nos dias atuais
não sei se vocês concordam comigo mas às
vezes eu tenho uma certa sensação de que
o mundo está digamos assim um tanto
desbussolado é como se nós como
humanidade tivéssemos assim em alto mar
e de repente toda tecnologia avançada
disse uma das bússolas modernas tivesse
dado uma pane hora em alto mar sem uma
bússola onde ao norte onde se navega
numa situação como essa pra onde se
navega no mundo como esse pois olha a
boa notícia que eu tenho pra dar pra
vocês é que como os navegadores de
outros tempos quando não tinha bússola e
que ele se conduziam olhando o céu das
estrelas fixas
os contadores de histórias
eles sabem ler o céu das estrelas fixas
portanto nós como humanidade não estamos
perdidos
os contos meus amigos e minhas amigas
são os celtas estrelas fixas
eles vêm de muito longe eles vêm dos
nossos ancestrais e eles falam de alguma
coisa que hoje falta
hoje a gente tem
muita informação e pouca sabedoria quase
nenhuma sabedoria você tem muita
informação e não ter sabedoria
sabe deus lá o que isso pode dar mas
esses contos dos quais falam os
contadores de histórias eles vêm de
muito tempo eles na verdade são a
experiência vivida pelos nossos
ancestrais que foi recolhida em forma de
contos essa a sabedoria porque sabedoria
não tem nada a ver com erudição
sabedoria algo que vem de uma
experiência vivida estada experimentada
muitas vezes e por muitos
então esses contos eles falam de uma
forma metafórica ele usa uma linguagem
metafórica eles usam uma linguagem que
contextualiza o que estão dizendo em
imagens
eles usam uma linguagem analógica o falo
por analogias eles falam de personagens
que hoje que quer pode dizer reis
rainhas príncipes e princesas
sim eles falam disso
mas tudo isso é uma linguagem simbólica
uma linguagem simbólica que pode falar
profundamente no nosso inconsciente e
pode ter a trabalhar profundamente no
nosso inconsciente e assim ajudar para
que a gente se transforme de uma forma
natural suave e sem dor
como hoje o tema aqui é liberdade plural
eu então escolher um conto pra trazer
pra vocês que fala disso
e vocês vão ver que todos os temas que
são temas polêmicos que são temas da
contemporaneidade e precisam ser falados
discutidos refletidos os corpos estão aí
para nos ajudar a refletir sobre esses
temas
então couto que eu vou terminar com
vocês que esse ponto é um conto do
início dos tempos quando a criação
estava sendo feita ainda
deus já tinha feito tudo mas ele tinha
guardado segredo para os anjos ele
não tinha contato para os anjos e quando
tudo estava pronto ele então convidou o
anjo gabriel para reconhecer como estava
a sua criação o planeta terra
gabriel veio com ele quando chegou ficou
encantado primeiro deus levou gabriel na
beira do mar e que abreu ficou encantado
com aquela água que vinha que voltava
que vinha que voltava que levava areia
que trazia areia gabriel desse senhor
mas é uma coisa magnífica deus disse pra
ele era pra ver mais um pouco e deus foi
com ele até uma cachoeira e quando ele
viu que aquela água caía do alto e batia
forte um lago azul ele disse senhor mas
aqui a superação total a deus disse
espera nem vou até a entrada da floresta
quando ele viu todas aquelas cores todos
aqueles verdes
ele disse olha não sei nem mais o que
dizer
ele então olhou pra cima olhou para o
céu e quando ele olhou para o céu
ele viu algo que eu pergunto a vocês por
exemplo se você olha para o céu que que
você vê no céu antiga azul e no weiss e
você que se vê no céu a lua e você o que
você pode ver no céu as estrelas e você
o que você pode ver no céu o sol ainda
bem que ninguém falou que é a camada de
ozônio porque às vezes tem alguns galos
que eu pergunto às pessoas fala camada
de ozônio furada
não não tudo isso tem no céu o sol as
estrelas a lua as nuvens o azul tudo
isso tem mas tem outra coisa no céu que
vocês não viram em pássaros que tinha
pensado nos passa você tem pesado nos
passos poder de vetá lá na hora da
criação
então quando gabriel olhou pra cima
tinha muitos pássaros em revoada mas
tinha um problema com eles
eles eram todos de uma cozinha
indefinida sem graça que não era nem
claro-escuro nem quente nem frio era uma
cor sem graça e todos tinham a mesma cor
eles lá vão eles tinham tamanhos
diferentes
eles tinham melodias diferentes tinham
plumagens diferentes mas a correta
sempre a mesma
gabriel olhou e disse senhor é com a sua
permissão
sem querer ofender naturalmente eu no
meu lugar não faria a inauguração ainda
deus porque gabriel se o os pássaros são
todos da mesma cor mesmo gabriel não é
que estava me passando desapercebido
é verdade estão todos da mesma cor
gabriel disse é digamos que para um
trabalho de profissional
os pássaros coloridos enfrentaria o
melhor do planeta diz deus disse você
tem toda a razão
toda a razão por isso que eu preciso de
anjos conselhos gabriel eu vou marcar um
dia uma hora e você vai convocar todos
os pássaros que eles estejam aqui nesse
dia nessa hora eu vou pintar todos eles
como eles quiserem
num mês assim foi feito
e no dia certo na hora certa ali estava
gabriel com uma lista de chamada enorme
de todos os pássaros
ele começou a fazer chamada mas a gralha
feito igual a lista levou a lista pra
longe a lista se perdeu e henrique
gabriel disse o japão tantos pássaros
aqui que não falta ninguém pode começar
o trabalho e deus tinha na frente dele
uma paleta de cores que ele tinha feito
especialmente para aquele dia cores que
ele ainda não tinha criado e criou
especialmente para a situação
então os parceiros fizeram uma fila o
primeiro da fila era a ara e quando a
área chegou e ela tomaria a cor que
agradaria toda a sua família eo
sendo pintado toda a família a partir
daquela hora seria daquela cor quando ar
a fio a paleta de cores de de usar a
luva era de armas e não possuía nenhum
me tudo sem esquecer a sul e no rio
vermelho aparecer ele não especificar
melhor não escape e amarelo e receber
pelo menos um pouco de cada um deus de
está bom
pintou a área como ela quis tem umas
azuis umas vermelhas umas vermelhas com
amarelo
são todas as paradas e ela fazia tanto
escândalo e ela fazia tanto chilique
enquanto deus pintava e ela gritava
tanto atrás dela vêm outro passa e
quando ela acabou de ser pintada ela
saiu voando e aparecendo por ali atrás
de outro pássaro que ainda não tinha
esse nome na época mas que depois passou
a ser chamado de pássaro preto que
quando ele viu a arara daquele jeito ele
pensou eu não quero fazer parte desse
bando
ele então chegou pra deus e disse eu
gostaria de uma coisa mais sóbria mas
discreta mais elegante deus disse mais
escolha um pretinho básico e cairia bem
eu disse pra ele você pode escolher um
pretinho é mais aveludado mais acetinado
ele disse um pretinho é aveludado com um
certo brilho deus pinto exatamente como
ele quis e quando ele saiu dali ele já
pegou o caminho contrário o caminho da
arara e depois vieram os colibris os
colibris acharam que se deus fizesse uma
misturinha entre uma coraci um verde
profundo um azul profundo e um cobre um
dourado prateado eles ficariam reluzente
são os beija-flores deus se exatamente
como eles quiseram depois vieram os
canarinhos canarinho só consegui enxergá
amarelo eles queriam amarelo de todas as
cores amarelo claro amarelo gema de ovo
amarelo puxar por laranja amarelo fez
busca por rosa mas todos só queriam
amarelo então os canários ficaram todos
amarelos mas eram tantos parceiros
tantos pássaros que eu poderia escrever
pra vocês cada um deles como chegou sua
vez de ser pintado mas eu vou ter tempo
pra isso aqui
até que por fim chegou a saída de sete
cores que não tinha esse nome ainda
quando ela chegou a paleta já tinha
poucas cores das tintas já estavam
acabando ela teve tanto pavor de ficar
sem ser pintada que ela pulou na paleta
e se esfregou de todas as formas
possíveis e ela passou rápido ela passou
uma e ela passou mas ela passou outras
ela pôs a cabeça dela e de repente ela
sabe que é demais
eu acho um pouco demais mas ela saiu bem
colorida
logo depois da saída de sete cores vem
chegando o rouxinol koch nou com aquela
coisinha ele disse o senhor eu sou eu
que moro mais longe foi o último a ser
avisado só tô conseguindo chegar agora
eu queria também se pintado como os
outros pássaros de deus disse olha sinto
muito o xenon
sinto muito mas como receber o óleo não
tem mais nenhuma cor aqui na minha
paleta é posso atender
mas eu só vou ficar assim
eu disse eu vou resolver o seu problema
pois aqui no meu dedo aí continuou posou
no dedo de deus pousou em deus disse
abri o bico contínuo deus pegou uma
gotinha de ouro que tinha um pincel era
a última gota que ele tinha em tô bem na
garganta do rouxinol e disse tá pronto
na garganta não posso andar com um bico
aberto
ninguém vai ver - só uma mecha deus diz
rocha estou muito cansado foi melhor que
eu pude fazer por você
é bom continuar ou sair dali assim meio
deprimido nem quis voar foi arrastando
as asas pelo chão se escondeu num
arbusto baixo
só que quando chegou a madrugada
e porque é da natureza do rouxinol
ele soltou seu canto a meus amigos
quando ele soltou seu canto todas as
feras que estavam ali já na floresta o
leão
a onça todos todos vieram e eles se
colocaram pelo chão pra ouvir o canto do
colch nou os outros pássaros todos
vieram e se colocaram diante daquele
arbusto para ouvir o canto do rouxinol o
canto do rouxinol é o canto dos amantes
porque o canto mais melodioso e é o
canto que fala de amor
assim quando a gente acha que tem alguma
coisa errada com a gente
a gente sempre deve se lembrar de que em
algum lugar em nós
existe uma gota de ouro que deus colocou
essa história ela fala de que o mundo se
não tivesse todas as cores que tem se
não tivesse todas as pessoas que têm que
fizessem todas as escolhas que fizer em
que quiserem tudo o que quiserem
elas apenas vieram aqui para manifestar
uma das facetas divinas
então seja o que você é
e não se esqueça de que você está aqui
manifestando uma das facetas divinas e
que portanto se a nossa origem é no amor
nós não podemos contradizer o criador
seria feio demais
então tem um grande poeta surf kids
falando de deus eu era um tesouro oculto
e criei as criaturas pra que elas me
revelar se cada um de nós é uma dessas
relações
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]